- I'm ready to school you guys
on Philadelphia slang.
(bell ring)
("Beat By Mix3d" by Carlos Cook)
- [Voiceover] Jawn. Jawn. Man.
Maybe a tool of some sort.
- The Philadelphia version
of like the outhouse.
- Is it like a joint?
- Like, there's a couple of
different ways you can use it.
One way you're like come jawn my group,
and then like this guy's
my jawn, 'cause I asked him
to jawn my group.
- You can use jawn with anything.
You could be like, yo, them jawns is hot.
Talking about your shoes,
you know what I'm saying,
so it could be mean anything.
- Look at that jawn.
- Drawlin'
I think of draw, I think
of like a southern draw,
but not somebody in Philly.
- That doesn't sound like
a good thing to be doing.
- Shorty so bad she got your boy drawlin'
over there, you know.
- Probably not like drawing.
- [Voiceover] No.
- Dammit.
- Taking too long to get ready.
Like a girl like she's drawlin'.
- My mom was drawlin' asking
me to get plane tickets
for my brother's wedding.
- [Voiceover] Schuylkill,
that sounds kinda crazy.
- You have your first day of
school outfit ready to go.
It's on point. Your jawn is on point.
That's your schuylkill outfit.
- You're like cool when
you're like in a crowd,
but like by yourself you're like a weirdo.
- Sounds like a French rapper.
I'm gonna guess it's a
French rapper who moved
to Philadelphia when he was around 16.
- The schuylkill is like a
road you take to get to Philly.
There's traffic on the schuylkill.
- Ard? We went to the ard last weekend.
It was crazy.
- Like when you're gonna go ham,
we're gonna go ard.
- Pirates coming from
Philadelphia and ards
is something that you guys just say.
- No man, you didn't totally
waste your architecture degree.
It's ard.
- [Voiceover] Widda Widdout.
- No onions on a cheese steak, right?
- Oh, that's without cheese, right?
- The cheese on the there,
but widdout the ketchup.
You know what I'm sayin',
on your Philly cheesesteak
or something like that.
- I love all this slang.
I'm gonna try and bring it to L.A.
- This jawn's clean as.
This is a clean jawn.
Yeah.